I'm Nick Montfort, Professor of Digital Media
in Comparative Media Studies and Writing.
I also teach at the School for Poetic Computation
in New York.
I studied creative computing and developed
computation art in poetry.
My computer generated poetry books include
#!, The Truelist, which is the first in the
recent "Using Electricity" series from Counterpath,
and Hard West Turn.
My digital projects, including The Deletionist,
Sea and Spar Between, and the translation
project Renderings.
These are all collaborations, are available
at NickM.com.
And I have MIT Press books, some collaborative,
some individually authored, which are The
New Media Reader, Twisty Little Passages,
Racing the Beam, 10 PRINT CHR$(205.5+RND(1)),
GOTO 10-- that's the reason why I have to
introduce myself, by the way-- Exploratory
Programming for the Arts and Humanities, and
most recently, The Future.
So I'll next introduce Stefan Helmreich, who's
on the opposite side of the table, who is
the Eltin E. Morrison Professor of Anthropology.
He received his PhD in anthropology from Stanford.
His research is focused on how biologists
think through the limits of life as a category
of analysis, which he's taken up in three
books-- Alien Ocean, Anthropological Voyages
in Microbial Seas; Silicon Second Nature,
Cultering Artificial Life in a Digital World;
and most recently, Sounding the Limits of
Life, Essays in the Anthropology of Biology
and Beyond.
While on sabbatical this semester, Stefan
holds fellowships from the John Simon Guggenheim
Foundation and at the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Studies, where he's completing
a manuscript that offers an ethnographic account
of how scientists measure, model, and monitor
ocean waves in an era of climate change.
Even though he is on sabbatical with these
two very, very desirable fellowships, he's
kind enough to join us for the panel.
So an extra measure of thanks to Stefan for
being with us today.
Next to me, Adam Haar Horowitz is a Masters
student in the Fluid Interfaces Group at the
Media Lab.
His work aims to augment human awareness,
translating advances in neuroscience into
the design of interventions and interactive
experiences across the arts and sciences.
He works on how technology can show us parts
of ourselves that remain otherwise invisible,
allowing for introspection, wellness, and
wonder.
He has background as a neuroscience tech at
MIT McGovern Institute, studying mindfulness
meditation and mind wandering, and as an artist
scientist at the Marina Abramovic Institute,
tying together neuroscience and performance
art.
His work has been shown at the Cannes Film
Festival, Transmediale, South by Southwest,
the Beijing Media Biennale, SESC Pompeia,
and the Boston Museum of Fine Arts.
Here at MIT, he leads the Skunk Works team
of MIT Hacking Arts.
His current projects include the microscopic
virtual reality adventures inside the human
body, along with dream control and capture
in the liminal space between wakefulness and
sleep.
Caroline A. Jones, far end of the table, studies
modern and contemporary art with a particular
focus on its technological modes of production,
distribution, and reception.
She is professor of art history in HTC, the
History, Theory, and Criticism of Architecture
and Art Program.
She's trained in visual studies and art history
at Harvard, doing graduate work at the Institute
of Fine Arts in New York, before completing
her PhD at Stanford University.
Previous to this, she worked in museum administration
and exhibit curation, holding positions at
the Museum of Modern Art in New York at the
Harvard University Art Museums, while she
also completed two documentary films.
Beyond her work at those institutions, her
exhibitions and films have been shown at the
San Francisco Museum of Modern Art, the Hirshhorn
Museum and Sculpture Garden in Washington,
DC, the Hara Museum Tokyo, Boston University
Art Gallery, and MIT's List Visual Art Center,
among other venues.
Caroline has written and edited a number of
books, most recently The Global Work Of Art,
which focuses on her ongoing research interests,
including globalism, the agency of the artist,
and new media art.
And finally, Agnieszka Kurant is an interdisciplinary
conceptual artist who examines how complex
social, economic, and cultural systems can
operate in ways that confuse distinctions
between fiction and reality, or nature and
culture.
Her work investigates the economy of the invisible,
in which immaterial and imaginary entities,
fictions, famines, energy flows, and emergent
processes influence political, economic, and
ecological systems.
She often collaborates with scientists, including
biologists, anthropologists, cartographers,
economists, computer engineers, and roboticists.
Many of her works simulate nature and behave
like living organisms, self-organized complex
systems, or bachelor machines.
In 2015, she did a commission for the facade
of the Solomon R. Guggenheim Museum in New
York.
2013 to 2014, she presented a major solo exhibition
at the sculpture center there in New York.
In 2010, she co-represented Poland at the
Venice Biennale of Architecture.
Her most recent exhibitions include commissions
for the Guggenheim Bilbao, SF MoMA, Cleveland
Triennial, and La Panacee, Montpelier, as
well solo shows at SCAD MoA, and CCA in Tel
Aviv.
Her work's also been exhibited at Palais de
Tokyo, the Tate Modern, the Kitchen, Witte
de With, Frieze Projects Projects, Moderna
Museet, MUMOK, Grazer Kunstverein, and Bonner
Kunstverein, Stroom den Haag, and Performa
Biennial.
Agnieszka is currently the Ida Ely Rubin Artist
in Residence at MIT'S CAST, and holds scholarships
at the Smithsonian Institute and the [INAUDIBLE]
Institute.
Well, as you can guess, we have a group with
some relevant expertise and perspective, but
also a diverse group.
And I'd say that the four of you, certainly
from different perspectives, you undertake
the types of inquiry, exploring, asking questions,
generating new sorts of insights.
This is something I think unites people at
the university generally, even if they're
doing very different sorts of activities.
They're somehow undertaking inquiry.
So since our occasion here is discussing Agnieszka's
work at MIT as an artist, I'd like to ask
how she inquires through art, and then invite
the others of you to explain how artistic
inquiry is similar to or different from the
types of inquiry that you pursue.
Thank you so much for hosting this wonderful
panel.
Thank you, everyone here, for joining me.
The point of departure of my work is the phenomenon
that nature and culture that are examples
of emergence and collective intelligence.
These phenomena happen in various complex
systems, the complex systems that can be a
termite colony, a human society, human brain,
the internet, the urban fabric, or even the
stock exchange.
There are systems with many components and
factors that are so complicated that are often
very difficult to anticipate what's going
to happen in them.
They evolve in a nonlinear way.
And I've been investigating these systems.
I want to show very quickly a couple of slides
of my points of departure of a couple of my
works.
I'm going to just comment with like one sentence
per image.
So this is an organism that inspired a lot
of my works, slime mold, that doesn't have
any nervous system, but consists of singular
cells that, when confronted with some form
of danger-- lack of nutrients or water-- aggregate
into a super organism, into one unit, and
moves as one unit, and displays signs of intelligence.
So it can even go through a maze.
And in fact, it was co-opted for computation
by scientists such as [? Andrea ?] [INAUDIBLE]
working in Great Britain, who was doing certain--
who was writing the Center for Unconventional
Computing using slime mold and other organisms
to perform various operations.
Another example of emergency and collective
intelligence in cultural bacteria are colonies
that perform groupthink.
And the work of Eshel Ben-Jacob, an Israeli
scientist who discovered that certain bacteria,
for example, make collective decisions where
they, let's say, decide to kill off half of
the colony for the collective good, future
good of the remaining bacteria.
And so it's kind of like, in fact, a visualization
of a groupthink, one can consider.
This is a social phenomenon that happened
on the platform called Reddit about a year
ago.
About 1 million people participated in it.
It was a sort of virtual fictional country,
universe, called The Place, where each participant
could place a single pixel wherever they wanted
in this virtual space.
And various emergent self-organized processes
emerged.
So a lot of a fictional characters, fictional
nations, cults.
This is an example of one of them.
This is the Black Void.
Another point of departure for a lot of my
research is this branch of science that analyzes
and grows artificial societies.
And it started in the early '90s, firstly
at the Santa Fe Institute by two scientists,
Epstein and Axtell.
But some of this earlier research has been
done by the economist Thomas Schelling.
It's basically a way of using algorithms to
calculate very complex systems of how societies
will behave, and the interplay between individual
decisions of citizens in a society.
So here are some examples of one of my works
using the artificial society models based
on the Thomas Schelling, the economist, his
model of self-segregation and how it can actually
be computed.
These are the works that stem from all this
research.
Sorry, I think we lost the image.
OK, thank you.
So these are the works-- this is a series
called [? AAI, ?] which are works that I outsourced--
crowdsourced-- to non-human agents.
Because I'm interested in also forms of non-human
intelligence.
In the times when other scientists are talking
about the fact that the intelligence is not
what the mostly Western culture assumes to
be individual and located in the brain, but
on the contrary.
It's distributed, and very external to the
brain, and it doesn't have to be human.
So a lot of my work are also taking this as
point of departure.
And so these works were outsourced to the
colonies of living termites.
Each sculpture is built by a colony of approximately
a million termites that were supplied with
alternative materials, such as pigmented sands,
particles of gold and crystals. and each colony
is isolated for about three, four months.
And they just built.
And each form is different.
Nothing can be anticipated.
And there in this hybrid forms that hover
somewhere between nature and culture.
And what is really interesting that the entomologists
point out how each single colony of exactly
the same species produces very different shapes
of termite mounds, which also corresponds
to a different collective personality of each
colony.
So just like humans, they can represent different
collective personalities.
Or just like social movements that sometimes
can be dynamic and fast, sometimes more slow,
dispersed, or concentrated, headless or not.
So these works also related to my interest
in self-exploitations present in society,
especially by corporations using algorithms
to harvest data of citizens who are completely
unaware of this.
So this is like a private distributed form
of self-exploitation.
That's a continuation of this work where I
am pouring hot zinc into abandoned termite
mounds.
And they form this negative casts of various--
so they're like internal portraits of various
societies.
They are poured in an African desert.
And these works, entitled The End of Signature,
that I've done various iterations of, are
related to my reflections about how the aggregated
value of social capital can not only be exploited,
which is unfortunately happening so often
in contemporary societies, but it can also
be precisely calculated and can be used or
analyzed for a good cause, and that we should
maybe try to embrace it.
So what I'm doing in this work is I developed,
together with computer programmers, an algorithm
that morphs thousands of signatures that we
first collect and scan into a collective signature.
And I've developed these collective signatures
for various social movements, communities,
and social groups.
The first one was a facade of the Guggenheim
Museum in New York.
And this is a collective portrait of all the
visitors, kind of alluding to the fact that
viewership today also became a form of labor,
visible labor, because audiences are constantly
Instagramming images and circulating images.
And it became a sort of form of invisible
labor and contributing to the value of the
artwork.
This is on the facade of the Cleveland Museum
of Art, where this is all the employees of
this museum who donated their signatures.
And this is a community of people living in
one building in Utrecht, which is like a last,
final island of public housing in the middle
of a privatized public space in central Utrecht.
And this a project that also using aggregation
of human behavior.
But in this case, it produced a certain level
of a collective Tamagotchi, or an organism,
or animatronic soccer ball in this case, that
is entitled a Quasi Object, making the reference
to Michel Serres' idea of how certain objects
need to be activated as they're circulated
between agents.
So different movements of soccer balls from
games played online by various internet users
who are aggregated and-- I don't believe that
we can play it, but it's moving-- actually,
it's an animatronic piece.
And finally, the series of works that I realized
here at MIT, they started with a series called
Production Line, where I started outsourcing
my works through human agents, multiplicity
of human agents, working on this new platform
that, in my opinion, is the beginning of the
new working class.
The platform is called Amazon Mechanical Turk,
but there are various similar forms that exist.
And they allow for crowdsourced labor, people
working on small tasks in front of their computer
screens online around the world.
And this platform can often, although not
always, become exploitative.
But could also be, possibly in the future,
used for the public good, because it allows
for collective intelligence experiments.
And it has been used for some social experiments.
So I took advantage of this platform to crowdsource
some of the works.
Thousands of people also working worldwide.
And the series is called Production Line,
where each worker was asked to draw a single
line.
And then they were algorithmically fused into
these collective drawings that were then outputted,
as you can see, with a pen plotter as one
single line, continuous line.
So each drawing represents an amalgamated
labor of, in this case, 500, 1,000, or 2,000
people, that each line has been drawn in a
different part of the world.
And what's most important about these works
is that I created a system that allows for
profit sharing.
So in a way, it allows for siphoning off the
money from the art market and redistributing
it among these workers.
So they are participating in the profits.
And when each of these works sells-- they
are being paid on the spot as they complete
their work.
But additionally, if the work sells, the proceeds
are evenly distributed among all the participants,
because Amazon Mechanical Turk platform allows
for storing their IP addresses.
So we can pay them bonuses at any point in
the future if the work sells.
This is a project that I developed here already
at MIT.
It was a generous collaboration from the CSAIL
team, Professor Boris Katz who is present
here, and also David Mayo and Andrei Barbu.
And this work is entitled Assembly Line, and
continues the idea of how to subvert the system
of like self-exploitation.
So in this case, we worked on the ways in
which-- how people donate or volunteer their
data, their bio data, online.
We transformed it into the ways in which people
taking selfies, or any kind of self-portraits,
how they could be aggregated into a collective
self-portrait of this collective worker that
this new working class constitutes.
So what you're looking at is like an aggregation
of about 10,000 people-- photographs, self-portraits
of like 10,000 people that are aggregated
into one.
And then, on the basis of several images that
we generated at CSAIL, I created these 3D
forms that are abstractions that represent
this collective self-portrait of this society.
And this project is now evolving further,
where workers from the same platform are going
to put together abstract machines from different
machine parts.
And then they will also be outputted in various
forms.
And lastly, I would like to show just one
minute of the project that I did here at MIT
entitled Animal Internet.
And I collaborated with Adam Haar Horowitz,
who's present here, as well as Agnes Cameron,
who I think is also here somewhere, and Owen
Trueblood and Ishaan Grover.
And it's, in many ways, like a culmination
of all this research between non-human intelligence
and collective intelligence and artificial
intelligence.
So what happens here is that, inspired by
the phenomena of animal internet, where a
lot of scientists are tracking animals all
over the world, on the one hand by putting
chips in animals and that they can be followed
digitally, but also by placing cameras in
jungles or in the North Pole.
And watching completely wild animals without
their knowledge.
Inspired by this phenomena, I realized that
since these animals have a kind of hybrid
life, because many of them are followed on
these webcams, they have websites, Facebook
pages, and a following of sometimes a couple
of hundred thousand people.
So the creates this kind of hybrid reality
between wilderness and culture.
So what we did together with the Hacking Arts
team is we created this project which consists
of two real webcams that are broadcasting
real wild animals.
One is a tiger in the jungle and one is a
polar bear in the North Pole.
And we, here at MIT, built two artificial
animals.
So they are animatronic animals.
We used artificial fur, so no animals were
harmed.
And basically, one of them, the one the upper
right corner, was powered by workers of the
Amazon Mechanical Turk that sent, as their
task for they were paid, they sent information
about how they were feeling.
Whether they were tired, hungry, angry, or
relaxed and happy.
And these aggregated emotions, like through
sentiment analysis and different kind of programs
that we use, we converted into various behaviors
of this fictional animal in a kind jungle
environment.
And the other camera is swarm of gerbils,
which was in a desert environment.
And this one is powered by a Twitter scraper
that we wrote.
So basically, we were monitoring Twitter accounts
of all the protest movements in the world,
and what kind of sentiments they are expressing,
whether it's frustration, hope, aggression.
And whether it's positive or negative.
And so this aggregated data from different
social movements were then powering a sugarscape
model, an artificial society model, that was
translated to a collective behavior of this
swarm.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks very much.
So first of all, I wanted to know, there's
five chairs I can see.
Please come-- and you don't even have to sit
in the front row.
Please come and occupy them.
And thanks very much, Agnieszka for-- so you
showed some images of your work, you told
us about your process and your interests.
But I wanted to ask one more thing.
I wanted to get you to say something about
how you work as an artist to do inquiries
specifically, because I've asked the others
to respond to this topic, like how the way
in which they inquire is different or similar
to your artistic inquiry.
So can you tell us?
Sure.
I mean, I was hoping that, kind of, this was
my answer, but of course-- well, I mean, I
collaborate with various scientists.
But I'm trying for my work not to be illustrative.
So it's always somehow twisted.
And I really like crossovers between different
things that maybe wouldn't crossover in real
life.
And to establish connections or dialogues
between sometimes scientists that maybe wouldn't
normally meet and wouldn't necessarily be
in a dialogue.
And even if it leads to miscommunications
or errors, but these errors could be productive.
So it's never-- although it is a collaboration
with scientists and other professionals, there
is always a very strong component of errorism,
as I call it, and irrationality, and slippages.
And it's just unexpected, non-linear things
that can happen.
Well, thanks very much.
I think that that's very consistent with what
you've shown, but you've highlighted these
two aspects that your work is collaborative.
It's not just the termites who are working
together with the slime mold, but that you're
working collaboratively and you're also interested
in the unexpected.
So let me ask for, perhaps Stefan, would you
like to ... next.
Sure.
Thanks.
And thank you, Agnes, again for that display
of incredible works.
Inquiry-- that's your question?
Yes.
I'm an anthropologist, and so my mode of inquiry
is ethnographic fieldwork.
And I spend time with people, with collectives,
and try to figure out what they're doing by
doing participant observation, by interviewing
them.
I spent a lot of time with scientists in particular.
And I bring a set of tools to that inquiry
which are things that I've gathered from the
social theory tool kit, which include analytics
of gender, and race, sexuality, ideas about
belief, ideas about conviction, hegemony,
practice, ideology, this whole kind of tool
kit of things.
And the idea is to bring those with me into
the zone of inquiry, hanging out with people,
and see what they do.
And sometimes they can explain things and
sometimes they break and they can't explain
things, or people give me other categories
and say, well, no, no, no.
This is not really about whatever you say
it's about.
Really, it's about complexity.
Or really, it's about nonlinearity.
Since I spend a lot of time studying scientists,
I got a lot of that.
They say, no, no, no, you're saying that this
has to do with culture and power, but really,
it's a scaling problem that's about a certain
set of non-linear dynamics, that properly
understood as emergent phenomena, would reveal
x, y, and z.
And then I can speak back to that and say,
well, yes, no.
So I think part of what I have in common with
Agnieszka, then, is that encounter with the
unexpected.
Just like this empirical work, and then the
attempt to find something and encounter something
that is surprising within that.
But then also just sometimes be assertive
about my own categories and say, this is patriarchy.
What is going on with this Kavanaugh thing
at the moment, that is patriarchy.
I am not buying it, that he's crying.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway.
It's his daughter's prayer.
I know.
His daughter's prayer.
Yeah, so.
OK, I think-- so Caroline was originally signed
up to be our respondent, so I think I'll give
her the privilege of going last.
And I'll give Adam the privilege of going
next.
Cool, thank you.
Yeah, I think that, if it's not immediately
apparent, I am at an earlier stage of question
asking than fellow panelists, so I will try
to contribute productive confusion, because
I am productively confused perhaps.
My background at the moment is a mix of neuroscience
and art.
And I wanted to tough quickly on why I think
that's a worthwhile mix, and why it's a contribution
to this conversation.
I think neuroscience stands out, especially
stands out at an institute like this because
it is such an unstable meeting ground of objectivity
and subjectivity.
It is an attempt at a third person study of
first person experience with first person
experience.
And it is so contingent and murky, it makes
it really exciting to study.
It also means that you don't get to stand
on two stable feet in either the realm of
the study of experience or the creation of
experience.
So my interest and excitement about Agnieszka
work and modes of inquiry were similar in
that there's a mix of stability and instability.
There's a clear picture that comes out of
a very murky collection of parts.
I'd say that it's something that's really
nice in terms of the collective piece that
this sort of subjective objective mix has
affected upon me is a sense of myself as collective.
I studied here a few years ago in the neuroscience
department, largely neural networks, which
changed my notion of self as a notion of there's
a me in a little bit of jelly.
And I've got to get it, and I'll get the jelly
eventually, to something more like I am temporal
dynamics.
I am rhythm.
I am time.
I am waves.
So the movement from functional neural anatomy
as a sort of phrenology to one of, instead,
dynamic networks, myself as collective.
And then I take it even further to-- if you
see something like a commisurotomy patient
in the neurosciences, somebody's who's had
their hemispheres split, something that has
stuck with me as a personal collective is
you might think that when you cut someone's
brain in half, it sort of turns off.
It doesn't.
Can keep functioning quite well, but some
develop alien hand syndrome, which people
might have heard of.
But you develop, essentially, hands that disagrees.
So one might want to button up, one might
want to button down.
You develop hands that have different information
schemes of the world.
One is more verbal, one has more sensitive
motor information.
And it's interesting that you can break in
that way.
But it's also interesting that if you were
currently broken in that way, broken in terms
of being a collective, you wouldn't know.
The notion that introspection as intentional
spotlight is a unifier of many selves.
That I might have, at the moment-- oh, I shouldn't
poke that.
I might have, at the moment, a more verbal,
a younger and older Portuguese speaking and
English speaking, a mix of cells with a mix
of knowledges.
And that my intentional spotlight is one of
those.
And so what I see inside is a necessary unification
of a possible split collective, if that makes
sense, has stuck with me in a big way.
And that's exciting.
I, at the moment, mostly study sleep, which
is also a weird way in which people break
very predictably.
If you get people at the right state of sleep,
they will lose syntax.
They will pull memories from different parts
of their lives that they wouldn't pull when
they were awake.
They'll be more fluid thinking.
They'll be more rigid thinking.
I work specifically in a weird sleep state
called hypnagogia.
And in that sleep state, you have a really
deep inversion of an organizing principle
to a collective intelligence, which is that
when you're awake, as a machine, you're generally,
I think, designed to associate two things
that are close together and make predictions
about the world accordingly.
There is an association in my head between
water bottle, water drinking, thirsty, et
cetera.
I'll move towards it when one concept comes
up.
In hypnagogia, you get a full inversion.
It becomes much harder for people to react
to things that are closely associated versus
associated at long distance.
So you have people have faster reaction times
when you associate a porpoise and a helicopter
than a porpoise and the ocean.
And this is exciting to me, because it's like,
whoa, I'm a collective which I can't introspect
on it, but I can get down to base rules and
switch those base rules and see a different
collective in different states.
If that makes sense, the sleeping self versus
not sleeping self.
So the collective question touches on a lot
of things I'm excited about.
Personal collectives, extended inactive intelligence,
which we'll probably get into later, because
I won't get into now.
And then lastly, excites me because the reason
that I'm here is that Agnieszka and Agnes
and Ishaan and many of us, and Gary and Leila
got to collaborate on a project in hacking
arts.
And I think that hacking arts is a sort of
nice demonstration of a certain organizing
principle of emergence, where I'm not a personal
believer in the idea that you can take a bunch
of dumb parts and put them together and get
something automatically intelligent without
some sort of organizing principle.
But I think that hacking arts kind of turns
out like that.
You just throw a bunch of people who are really
different into a room and they kind of bounce
off each other.
And things pretty predictably come out.
And that's really been very exciting for me
as a person who gets to guide that and can't
guide that.
So yeah, I would say that hacking arts, for
me as a collective, there's the-- I think
it's Kahneman line about emergence.
Oh no, it's Danny Hillis.
It's like how can a bunch of stupid things
come together and be smart?
I'm really interested in hacking arts, with
how can a bunch of smart things come together
and be stupid, in terms of producing absurdity
or getting past utility.
If that makes sense.
Hopefully that's what we're doing tonight.
All of that to say I'm confused by my disciplinary
path.
I think it's a productive confusion that contributes
to the notion of being a confused collective,
which is how I introspect upon myself, and
also how I try to work in the world, which
is what I think hacking arts does and I think
the project did.
I think that's why I'm here.
All right, thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So Caroline can tell us some about her methods
of inquiry and her connection.
Well, I'm actually very moved to respond to
Adam.
This is not the gestalt theory that I was
taught by Rudolf Arnheim.
So I'm really excited that neuroscience is
in a place where it can think about dynamic
flow and collectivities that split and come
back together.
I had Lydia bring in this video, which you
can watch.
And if you get bored with me, or even if you
don't.
Eventually about 15 seconds in, 20 seconds
in, you'll see the slime mold social amoeba
form an aggregate.
And what's amazing about this unicellular
organism that emerges into a multicellular
organism is that it does so while each cell
maintains its identity, as it were.
It doesn't presumably have consciousness as
we hubristically imagine it.
But it's organizing itself into to this slug,
which is then going to move off to the left
as an organized entity looking for food, as
a collective that chemically directs itself
towards the food that it might be able to
sense in its medium.
And what's cool about this scientific video
is that at the very end of this loop, you'll
see this slug become a vertical fruiting body.
So it actually is coming up vertically from
the agar plate right here and standing up
and going like, OK, I give up.
There's no food.
I'm going to make spores.
And what's hilarious about the science of
this is that it's attracting people that are
just incapable of thinking of this without
words like altruism, and selfishness, and
sacrifice.
So if you don't get to be spore, you lose,
Buckwheat, in the science about this kind
of material.
So I look to culture, as an art historian,
I look historically to see what artists have
done with certain generative concepts.
And in that sense, I'm very much fond of Stefan's
tool kit.
And we've collaborated on some things together
with great pleasure.
So I look historically at what they've left
us traces.
Texts, images, journals, interviews.
And then as a critic in the contemporary world,
I work with contemporary artists whose work
excites me very much and seems to propel ethnography
of the future, if you will.
I mean, something coming into being.
A kind of emergent thinking that I want to
be part of, or I'm want to see in the world.
So Agnieszka's presentation was wonderful.
Her article in Cabinet is very interesting
about the-- I have to read the title-- the
uncomputables.
But where slime mold in her thinking is a
kind of model for a certain calculational
possibility, I'm actually looking for something
else in slime mold.
So the artists working with biological material
that have taught me things, that have helped
me think, are ones that are crafting what
I've been calling biofiction.
And they've been doing so for-- OK, here's
the Utopian project-- a cultural evolution
that I want to see happen that I'm calling
symbiotics.
I just use whatever platform I have to tout
this stupid neologism.
The idea of the ontic is that which is.
And the idea of symbiosis is that's what we
are.
We are slime mold.
We are completely, pathetically dependent
on our environment, on our planetary systems,
on the scrum of life of which we are a part.
And the sooner we can get rid of the fantasy
of the selfish individual, the selfish gene,
whatever the selfish thing is, the sooner
we can get rid of that the better.
The sooner we can think together to sense,
somehow, our complete dependence on the planetary
systems that make our consciousness and our
lives possible, the better.
So art that does that is art that, at the
moment, I'm excited by and want to celebrate,
because I have another fantasy, which I'm
sure my anthropologist friend could disabuse
of, that we make art to externalize something
that then changes use.
That then evolves us to a different kind of
creature.
So this is my fantasy.
And I celebrate that contemporary art as a
place that I don't know how to get to, but
they seem to be getting there.
They seem to be emerging into that project
of collective-- I don't want to call it intelligence--
collective action, collective sensing, collective
being in a chemical bath, which is undertheorized.
The binary bits of neural nets.
Forget about the synapse, which is a gap that
has to be bridged by wet chemicals.
So for me, these cultural conversations, these
metaphors we live by are metaphors that will
help us possibly live in the future.
And if we can't do it, we deserve to be extinct.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that's heartening.
[APPLAUSE]
I think that that needed to be heard.
And I would say that if I were to be an ethnographer,
I would want to be an ethnographer for the
future, definitely.
So I appreciate that concept also.
Actually, I want to ask, among the many topics
we have related to neuroscience and biology
and your artistic connection to science, I
wanted to talk about one related to culture
and power.
Specifically that a lot of the formulations
of collectively that we look to, things like
Amazon Mechanical Turk, are pretty hierarchical.
Even something like Wikipedia, while it isn't
modeled in the same way with the payment structure,
there are definitely heirarchies and heterarchies
at the very least of power, authority, expertise.
And those are reflected in the content of
that, in many ways, miraculous project, but
one that has its problems also.
Are there examples of human collective intelligence
that you can think of where people aren't
exerting power over each other, where there
is a more genuine form of collectivity?
Or are there ways in which we're moving toward
that.
I mean, this may relate, Agnieszka, to your
work in providing proceeds from art sales
to the participates in Amazon Mechanical Turk.
But how is it that we can make a move toward
non-hierarchical types of collective work
among humans?
I think it's an interesting question.
And one of the reasons why I was fascinated
by this research into artificial societies
is because this was the first time, I believe,
that modeling very complex behavior of societies
allowed us to understand that any system of
this complexity naturally goes into a disequilibrium.
So even if you give people equal chances on
the start, it will, unless it's monitored
constantly.
And the simple-- in my opinion, the simple
and short answer to your question is no, there
are no systems like this, because immediately,
unless it's heavily monitored and supervised,
which could entail other problems, such as
surveillance, every system is going to naturally
push into some kind of disequilibrium and
kind of disproportionate relations of power.
And I'm obviously exploring.
And that's why I'm looking for like various
weird phenomena that emerge out of the blue
that are really like bottom up emergent processes
that sometimes look strange.
We don't really know what to make of them,
what is their purpose.
Some of them almost have a structure of artworks.
Apart from the experiment that I've shown,
there was this experiment, another experiment,
called take care of my plant, which is kind
of absurd.
It's like different people, also in Reddit
platform, different people were asked to participate
in watering this one plant.
So they were sending comments through a platform.
And this plant was being nurtured by thousands,
or hundreds of thousands of people.
What does this mean?
What is the purpose of it?
It wasn't even a social experiments.
It was something, some emergent action.
And I think that the only hope for me is that
looking at spontaneous emergent phenomena
of society, of course including social movements,
but even these very often turn to be hierarchical,
or turn to be-- and there is obviously this
question of headless revolution, whether it's
possible or not, how effective can it be or
not.
But I think this is why it's very interesting
to have this debate with anthropologists,
because looking into very strange social phenomena
throughout the history of human civilization
maybe can provide some examples.
But I am rather skeptical.
Could I make a comment on this?
Because I think the idea of our present models
of artificial intelligence as being somehow
exemplary is deeply flawed.
Because each of those are based on code that
gets handed on and passed on and is totally
baked into hierarchies of what it was built.
There's even junk in there that's like [? chat.
?]
So I'm informed by the work of Wendy Chun,
who's a great media theorist, who traced back
the homophily algorithms of Facebook.
If you like this-- like in Amazon.
If you like this, you'll like this, right?
The so-called echo chamber that we find ourselves
in socially to a pioneering study in the 1950s
by an urban theorist.
And Nick probably knows all of this and remembers
the guy's name.
Anyway, it was two paradigms of which only
one was chosen for the future development
of all sorting algorithms.
The two paradigms were birds of a feather
live together, sort together.
And the other urban study of neighborhoods
was opposites attract.
These two bits of difference liking and difference
hating sort completely differently.
And the one that software developers chose
was homophily, was birds of a feather always
want to flock together.
That's because they weren't in a dream state.
They couldn't think of the opposite being
this far apart.
It's because they were--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--living in the 50s, when redlining was happening
in their neighborhoods.
They were already whites who were benefiting
from that privilege.
You know what I'm saying?
So even though the urban study guy wanted
to look at the nonracist model, that's not
what got baked into all of our systems.
So I, as a culturalist and a historian, want
to insist that there is nothing neutral about
the intelligences as we now define them.
And when I was privileged to be at a session
with Danny Hillis on possible minds with a
bunch of robotics people who now have second
thoughts, mm, what about AI.
It's scary, actually.
Anyway, I said, guys, what about the immune
brain?
You know?
It learns.
It Teaches us.
It remembers things.
It forgets things.
It's distributed.
It's not exactly conscious, but maybe it is.
We don't really know.
The point is it works both to take in and
to reject.
And the fact that all we spend our money on
is antibiotics and the probiotics aren't even
regulated by our federal drug authority tells
us something about how our root algorithms
are organized.
So I'm looking for different metaphors to
get going.
And I'm looking to art for doing that.
Well, if there's more to say on this, we can,
but there's also other topics to discuss.
Priorities, power, gender, yeah.
There's more to say on this.
There's something--
Particularly if there's anything hopeful.
I don't know if I'd add something hopeful,
but I might add something rhizomatic or more
linky than nodey, in terms of hierarchy setups.
I think that the AI is scary take is interesting.
I think, also, that the way AI is changing
us in the way that we see technology is a
sort of a different conversation which gets
left out sometimes in terms of how is it that
we're relating to those sorting algorithms,
and how are they changing us as information
processors and packers.
Something that I wanted to add, which might
be interesting to the hierarchy conversation,
is transactive memory as a linking concept.
Meaning culture as a form of collective memory
that no one person holds.
And the notion that I, as an individual in
a culture, don't need to remember, necessarily,
the history of when this space was burned
or built.
I need to remember the person who remembers
the history.
And the notion that that sort of linking is
being extended to such a great degree with
current information and sorting becoming so
effective, where I know-- not only do I not
need to know when the house was built or burned,
I barely need to remember the person who remembers
the name of the house.
And as you get more effective linking in this
way, I think you start to live more in the
links rather than in the nodes of information.
So I think the interesting thing about it--
in my lab, we do some work on tech and memory.
And there is really nice work showing that
as you, for instance, teach people about Wikipedia
pages, they stop remembering that content
and they start remembering how to find the
content.
They move towards the links.
I think that I see this in myself in things
like family history, in myself like working
in a lab with distributed kinds of expertise.
I don't really feel like I need to know much
about circuits, because there's a person next
door who knows a lot about circuits.
I'm really curious about the kind of hierarchy
that's turning me into.
And what it means if I live more in the links
to information and less in terms of nodes,
less in terms of expertise, less in terms
of that sort of hierarchy, and what it means
to start forgetting the things and remembering
the paths to the things.
Forgetting the name of the thing.
So, well, let me move on to another question,
to which the answer may also just be no.
But I'm wondering, because we're characterizing
so many things as collective, we're talking
about the self, the mind.
Marvin Minsky, of course, had this concept
of society of minds, which makes a metaphor
to the neural activity and the brain in terms
of society.
Obviously, there's the collective nature of
society.
And there's particular online labor platforms,
there's collaboration also, artistically and
scientifically and otherwise.
So I guess what I'm wondering is whether it's
useful to distinguish-- is it redundant to
just say collective intelligence?
Is there another kind of intelligence?
Is there a reason that we would even say that
to put an emphasis on something, what are
you distinguishing it from?
I'm not sure if this is also part of the question
that we were discussing earlier about the
distinction between intelligence and creativity.
I think that these two questions are related.
And I think that, in principle, in my opinion,
is a false binary.
Because any kind of creativity involves intelligence,
and vise versa.
And a lot of this conversation about creativity
versus intelligence was actually generated
by neoliberal discourse, Richard Florida,
and exploitation of this creative intelligence
for purposes of corporations, for example.
And I think that this whole binary is completely
false.
But what, for example, is interesting for
me in terms of collective intelligence, and
why I think that it's important to distinguish
it, even if it's [INAUDIBLE] maybe, is the
fact that, especially with cultural, but especially
Western culture in particular, has this tradition
of thinking about intelligence as individual.
And located in the brain and human.
And I really appreciate what Caroline was
saying.
I absolutely share your interest in this [? real
?] that this anthropomorphization of intelligence,
and the idea of this individual intelligence,
it has to stop.
Because not only, obviously, scientists are
observing since a long time, that intelligence
is distributed.
That it's external to the brain.
And it can be collective.
It can be also non-human.
And intelligence, essentially, is alien, I
would even say, in a way.
And especially with the microbiome research
that is both inside of our bodies, but also
is external in a way.
So it's both and non-us.
And I think that it actually brought the whole
conversation-- and I'm coming back to the
things we said here about AI-- the whole anthropomorphization
of artificial intelligence.
That it's a single brain, or it's a single
entity, or a robot or something.
It's just like such a blind alley, because
there are actually all these other forms of
intelligence that-- and in fact, which corresponds
with neural networks, which are used by scientists.
That it is a multiplicity.
It's a network.
It's a [? collective.
?]
So it's useful to ask, who is served by the
fiction of the solitary unit?
And the market is very well served by this.
So the ICA just opened a beautiful show with
Jason Moran.
And their stated intention was to sort of
break with the art world's fixation on the
individual and talk about collaboration.
But it's called Jason Moran.
You know what I mean?
So they can't really get there because they're
inside.
They're inside the art market.
But they know they want to get there, right?
So you can just see the function of these
ideologies as they operate.
I mean, so one thing you could come to with
the term for lack of intelligence, perhaps
also like situated or distributed intelligence,
is it doesn't mean that there is another kind.
It means that we need to explain something
about the nature of intelligence by adding
these terms.
We need to adjust our appraisal at the--
Well, and that, to Adam's point, there's also
the binary with dumb.
So I mean, we function with that.
And I'm going to-- Nick didn't want to talk
about this, but MIT has a whole Center for
Collective Intelligence.
And what they're trying to do over there at
the Sloan School is actually not be dumb,
not have algorithms determine our president,
for example.
And that is a very important project, even
though it operates within all the hierarchies,
with all the biases that could possibly cooked
into all this.
At least there are some humans that are trying
to move the debate within things that we have
already unleashed, that are already operating
in fairly stupid ways to run our social lives.
I want everyone to talk about what they want
to talk about [INAUDIBLE].
I just wanted to quickly-- I think that what
Professor Jones said about moving from emergent
intelligence to emergent being.
I think it's a really interesting comment.
If smarter is what we're trying to be when
we group together or not.
There's nice research out of MIT-- I think
it was from [? Malone, ?] and then more recently,
it's Sandy Pentland.
And Media Lab doing work on what it is that
predicts effective collaboration.
It's never picking an individual member to
be smarter than the rest of the group and
talk more, or even three within 10.
It's always a measure of social cohesion that's
a best predictor of output.
And I think that that's research that people
have come across and has been around for a
while.
There's more recent research, which I think
is interesting, in what Professor Jones just
said about our country making collective decisions
which we'd question, which is that that measure
of social cohesion is no longer a good measure
of group output if those people are not in
person, if they're communicating over text
on the internet.
Then that is no longer the measure that predicts
group intelligence as it was measured in the
original [? Malone ?] work.
I find that pretty scary in terms of the ways
that we're going to relate at scale.
And so I really appreciate the move from emergent
intelligence, emergent being, whether intelligent
is what we're aiming for, and whether intelligent
is what we're actually studying.
I think it's really exciting that 100 ants
on a flat surface walk in a circle and die,
and 500,000 can see the world.
I don't know if what they're doing is being
intelligent.
I think it's cool to complicate it.
So let me ask, because the topic has come
up, about authorship, one might say, but also
being an artist as a singular type of activity,
the myth of the individual author and individual
artist as something that's promulgated.
I mean copyright law coming about to be able
to make work marketable.
And of course, the art world has its own version
of this also.
It's not just in publishing, right?
So it's actually the case that this work arises,
even if it's not done explicitly by collaborative,
even if it's not Shakespeare working his plays
with a troop of actors.
Or someone with editorial supervision and
collaboration.
It occurs in the social context.
It occurs collectively in various ways.
And I think we recognize that the standard
individual intelligence, individual creativity
model is an outmoded one.
But then, I guess, the question is, what's
going to happen with it?
Is it just going to increasingly be recognized
by the communities that have a stake in this?
Or is it going to be pushed back and further
assertion.
Where do you see it going in the future?
Our ethnographer of the future at the end
of the table.
Well, I think the art world will be the last
to go.
So I'm fascinated by artists who have some
experience with, say, the theatrical arts,
or the music world, like Jason Moran.
There are very well elaborated, controlled
systems of credit and sharing in those worlds,
even down to jazz improvisation, where it's
like it's your turn the drummer.
The second you get into the art world, everything
changes.
So an artist like William Kentridge, who loves
opera, who wishes he could just do opera,
needs to go over here and make a drawing and
sell it for $300,000 so he can make an opera,
right?
Because opera doesn't make money.
Opera is collaborative.
Opera has many, many people working on it,
all of whom get paid and are given credit.
So ironically, the thing he can do himself
is paid more by the art world than the thing
that has to pay all those other people.
That obscures the fact that his workshop has
a stable of very committed people that he
has worked with, almost in a theatrical troupe
impresarial way, for decades.
And their name does not go on the drawing.
But let me ask.
So i understand that from the credit perspective.
But let me ask this.
Isn't some of the value, maybe most of the
value, of art that we can talk about it and
we can share our appreciation of and our understanding,
our reflection on it?
And doesn't that come from knowing about artists
and their practices?
And if we have something-- I mean, Agnieszka's
work is interesting because we know about
her trajectory as an artist and the contextual
situation of the other works that she's done,
and her thinking and her perspective and the
way that she works.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I think her work is unusual in the amount
of credit that she shares and the discussion
of her collaborators.
I think that's unusual.
And I think that's admirable.
But we have to admit, we're not as interested
in her Turkers' stories as we are in her--
But that could be a great hypnagogic reversal.
That could be a great hypnagogic reversal.
Instead of averaging those emotions.
Yes, absolutely.
Right?
Drilling down.
And there is some effort to do that.
There is some work with these affective committees.
I think-- I'll just throw out another example
of collectives, which I would love to get
Agnieszka'a response to.
So in Dafen, which is the special economic
zone of Shenzen, the art village was collected
by the party state in China and told that
they should each paint their dream on this
particular canvas.
But on the other side, they should paint an
exact replica of this thing over here, this
little chip, this little photographic chip.
And they're very highly skilled at replicating
photographic information on whatever they're
given.
And when all of the tiles were put together
by the party state, they made a giant Mona
Lisa.
Not from their dreams, which are now on the
back of the canvas, their individual dreams.
But the front, which they were given as actual
living human mechanical Turkers, now composes
the Dafen Mona Lisa, which is so much better
than Leonardo's because we all made it together,
right?
So this trope of the collective is also a
cultural conceit.
And it bears with it tremendous power for
the political narrative.
So the hierarchy that determined which worker
would get which chip, which piece of the Mona
Lisa, is erased in the discourse about this
wonderful collective.
So you can always do that interesting analysis
of the history and how it works with these
concepts.
The name, the Mechanical Turk, is an obscene
orientalism that we just use without reflection.
But it already encodes the hierarchy of this
automaton without brain that will perform
upon demand.
I mean, so ugh, can we reverse that narrative
in any way with that platform?
I mean, I think we'd have to rename it.
Yes, absolutely.
I mean--
I'm not sure the other platforms are better,
though.
Yes.
There are [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] is the other [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So it does seem like historicizing these terms
is one way to break them, right?
The history of the collective, and collective
farming in the former Soviet Union is a different
kind of collective than the kind of Utopian
thing that maybe we're talking about a little
bit here, right?
And I think a lot of discussions of collective
intelligence are-- and emergence intelligence--
are haunted by kind of reductionist methodological
individualism.
That somehow there's this collective emanation
of emergent intelligence, and then it's made
of these binary little bits of individuals,
which is kind of Western, liberal contract
theory from Hobbes to Russo to John Locke,
et cetera.
Like mitzy monads that just sort of percolate,
right?
With no mediating or middle structure.
But I think that maybe that's something we
could think about, is what would be a meso-theory?
There's something that intervenes between
the kind of monads and this collective effervescence.
Well, let's go there.
Because the monad is merely an invagination
or an extrusion from a single divine body.
So I mean, we could, right there with the
monad, we could get some fuzz and some vagueness
and some sliding going on.
It's the bit that I think we struggle with.
I would have two comments to this exchange.
One is about coming back again to this question
of creativity and different projections and
anthropomorphizations of AI and its uses.
And something that is specific, I think, about
intelligence that is not machining is a certain
aspect of irrationality, or unpredictability,
or uncomputability.
And I think that the problem that is now starting
to be recognized by scientists, that it's
this tendency to anthropomorphization, but
also of the AI.
And trying to think about how this could be
created, and how could we, for example, create
an artificial intelligence artist using algorithms.
I mean, one of the questions is like, how
do you actually imitate not the intelligence,
but precisely the dumbness, the stupidity,
or the thing even more broadly, some kind
of irrationality of various kinds, including
stupidity?
Or naivete or-- and this is becoming-- I mean,
it's probably, again, an unbridgeable challenge.
The machines have their own type of stupidity.
It's called glitch.
It's called a glitch.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
That could be employed in these kind of things.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
But they are different glitches.
They don't have to imitate human writers or
artists.
Agreed, but there are different kinds of errors
and glitches.
And of course, some artists are exploring
these glitches, machining glitches.
But actually, the kind of irrationality, there's
something particular about it.
And I think that the uncomputability of collective
social behavior, which we can obviously, now,
with all the algorithms that we have at hand
to, for example, anticipate an election result
and other phenomenon.
They've become useless at the end of the day,
because so many irrational factors sometimes
play into it.
I think that I see-- I kind of see some hope
in it, because wouldn't it be absolutely terrifying
if everything could just be computed?
And we would be able to anticipate everything,
like in terms of any kind of creative-- excuse
the word-- process of any kind.
Not in culture, but in any.
I think, actually, this would-- humans need
not only this sense of being able to control
things, because obviously, what is the ability
to calculate things?
It's obviously connected to our ability to
control things.
And the more that we have uncomputables and
irrational factors, this actually-- the fact
that we still can have it, thank God, is a
positive thing.
But I don't know for how long, but I'm hoping
that maybe always.
And another point that I wanted to make about
the questions of authorship and where art
and culture could go, I mean, one of my main
areas of research is where is culture going
to evolve?
Where it's going.
And I think that we're living in, for many
reasons, horrifying times.
But for other reasons, very interesting times,
because we can witness as culture evolves
in front of our eyes, because some things
are happening so fast.
But one negative aspect of the evolution of
culture is that it used to be produced collectively.
And things like the Bible, or the mythologies
were important products of culture with multiples
anonymous, mostly anonymous authors.
And even today, a lot of people are indicating
that even constructs like Homer, or maybe
to some degree even Shakespeare, actually
constitute a multiplicity or, or certain diversity
of more than just one author.
And at some point of cultural evolution, we
arrived at the point where, basically, yes,
as Caroline pointed out, cultural industries
or proto-industries capitalized on the fact
that if you have a singular author, it's going
to be easier to capitalize on it, to market
it.
Yeah, and we're like at the point total absurd
of this, that it's a total alienation, almost,
of the product.
And I think that creativity is a social relation,
first and foremost.
And what happened in culture is that creativity
became a relation between the product and
the author.
And this is why, precisely as Caroline was
pointing out, that the objects that were touched
by the artist hand-- why is painting today,
as for example, like Isabella Grav very interestingly
analyzes, like why has painting been so fetishized
and is reaching the highest prices is because
a lot of people who understand culture in
a very basic way, they want to have the stigma
of the artist, the touch of the artist's hand,
even if it's mechanized to some degree.
But still, some kind of expanded notion of
painting, or expanded notion of sculpture.
Something that had a contact with the living
body of the artist.
And it's obviously just another commodification
of a process that originally was general,
intellect, multitude of various people.
Let me ask, though, because it seems to me
that it is possible, if you're mentioning
with regard to Homer, the Odyssey author,
the Iliad author-- we call him Homer.
That we can have works that don't have an
author, and that are creative, and influential
socially.
But we can't have something creative or influential
socially without some type of cultural context.
We wouldn't say, oh, this is very creative
meteorite that landed on the ground.
I mean, it has to be a work that has some
meaning situated socially that's there.
And so--
I don't know, it it looked like Agnieszka's
sculpture, we might say, what a creative looking
meteorite.
That's true.
Yes.
In other words, if it had certain orders that
we associate-- But there was also the selection
of materials.
There was also an arrangement of--
But upon first contact, if it rockets out
of the sky, it lands in front of you, and
it looks like her anodized metal thing--
This is an empirical question.
If we go to the Museum of Natural History
and we take one of the meteorites and we put
it in an art gallery--
Oh, it's been.
Olafur Eliasson already did that.
But I'm making a different point about where
culture comes from.
So if it rockets out of the sky, it lands
in front of us, and it looks like Agnieszka's
object, I'm going to say there's probably
some culture in this.
So I'm supplying-- I'm part of the-- what
I love, what Adam mentioned, about this collective
project that defers memory and stores it in
other people, and so on and so forth.
I mean, maybe it would be a provocative suggestion
to say, are we allowing corporations to have
collective intelligence?
They're already fictive persons.
They're already fictive bodies.
What are we-- we have many, many entities
in our own culture that are kind of allowed
to operate as if they possessed intelligence.
And some of the AI crowd I was hanging out
with was saying that this is already the singularity.
This is already an artificial intelligence.
Their claim is that the CEO has to listen
to this aggregate that is this corporation.
That the CEO is a fictive individual who doesn't
actually control what's going on with this
emergent property which is called the capitalist
corporation.
So I take that pretty seriously.
There's a history to that.
We decided to make them people.
We decided to let them have free speech.
We decided to let have certain ways of storing
their capital and moving it around that didn't
involve our separate wishes.
So some have argued that this is already the
singularity of a general intelligence appearing
in our social organizations.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--language and have conversations with them
to ask them to treat us nicely.
I think that's called a chat room.
I think I do that on my interfaces.
I'm also thinking back to the 19th century
and Charles Babbage's notion of intelligence
as not only a kind of capacity or a faculty,
but also as knowledge about the conduct of
calculation.
And Charles Babbage not only being famous
for thinking about early theory in computation,
but also somebody who is very interested in
factory manufacture, and in organizing the
shop floor, and making the claim that having
the knowledge about how to organize the shop
floor meant having intelligence.
And the intelligence resided not in the craftspeople
or in the factory workers on the floor, but
rather in the manager.
So already there, there's a notion of-- there's
already a kind of relation of production that
produces a kind of notion of what counts as
intelligence.
And it's gathering together of a collectivity
into the category of the stake of the individual.
I just want to quickly to the point of irrationality
and authorship in the corporation.
I think another institution project director
that's at the table and in the room, the sort
of collective scientist and the collection
of facts that science produces.
And the notion of authorship in that realm
I think is really interesting.
In my experience, there's almost an opposing
problem, which is that-- in my experience,
the art world, art rarely exist without an
author.
In my experience of science and scientific
discussions about how memory does or doesn't
work, or is split or not split, or stays or
doesn't stay, facts are split from their producers.
And I think this is interesting to Professor
Jones' point in terms of power in code also,
the notion of math or software as neutral
and without author.
And then in the science world, the notion
of facts as without author.
And what that produced is-- and why that comforts
us.
I think it eliminates subjects and the limitations
of specific cohorts of subjects.
It eliminates the scientist as subjective.
It eliminates the study of myself as study
of other, which I think is comforting as a
construction of objectivity and a way to study
ourselves or know ourselves, actually.
But I think in the same way, there's an interesting
psychology of the artist as always author,
or science as without author, sort of exiting
[INAUDIBLE] science.
There is an interesting psychology to why
I think it's comforting to consider myself,
or ourselves, or intelligence as a collective
in that it lets you understand and not understand
at once.
And that's OK.
Where you can say, you can boil down to parts,
and I can see parts.
And so I'm a materialist scientist, and that
is comforting.
But at the same time, there's a sort of weak,
epic phenomenalism where you can say, those
parts construct a mystery.
And that leaves some space for freewill, or
soul, or whatever you'd like to put in there.
So I think the psychologies of all of these
are really interesting.
The psychology of giving personhood to corporation.
The psychology of giving, perhaps, too much
personhood to an art project, or perhaps taking
personhood out of a scientific project.
Well, I think we should break the hermetic
seal around the five of us and see if there's
some questions from our continuing audience
that's been so kind to [INAUDIBLE].
We'll be voting them up and down over here.
We'll be voting your questions up.
Let's-- yes.
Hi.
I'm at the MIT Center for Collective Intelligence.
I have a lot of questions, comments, [INAUDIBLE]
I told that this was coming.
The one that I believe-- it's not clear to
me yet how this panel defines intelligence.
Let's be pushy.
One of the things that I was wondering is,
if intelligence and creativity would be considered
distinctly, as some people, for instance,
in computational creativity like to think
of creativity as being distinct from artificial
intelligence the way that problem solving
behavior is treated there.
So Agnieszka's perspective was not-- was that
they shouldn't be though of separately.
What's intelligence to you?
I'm going to defer to the ethnographer.
I'm interested in the actors categories.
So my main question with the slime mold is,
what is this thing that you mean when you
say the word intelligence?
So mostly, I want to ask that question, not
answer it.
I actually like what you presented there,
that example, a single episodes And the way
that you actually described it as a collective
aggregation instead of collective intelligence
I didn't see intelligence there.
But I was able to see this collective But
that's based on my perception and understanding
of what intelligence means.
But I was very interested to hear what your
perspective was.
So I think that the emerging ideas of art
and culture that I see as celebrating in some
way, as some demi hemi semi collective up
here, is to question the computational motherboard
as the metaphor for intelligence.
The baggage manager, the man behind the curtain,
the [INAUDIBLE] or whatever [? Wiener ?] call
it.
The kind of gubernator, the cybernetic steersman
to kind of question that.
And to say that it's time to acknowledge that
other things are happening, things that seem
to have purpose and form and seem to push
things into being that are not necessarily
driven by some rational intelligence at the
center.
So do we want to abandon the word, or do we
want to retool it?
That's kind of the project.
That's the question at hand.
I'm not sure which is-- maybe it's fatally
compromised.
It certainly has its sociological and racist
baggage.
So maybe we--
But again, there's a market there as well,
right?
When I wanted to get some digitized images
for teaching, I got nowhere with the library.
They didn't have any money.
But when I called it an IS&T problem, and
I called it an information management problem,
suddenly I had all these people saying, we'll
write some software for that.
So they thought they could sell an intelligent
system of digital-- like they kind of forgot
PowerPoint existed.
But they thought they could sell an intelligent
teaching platform.
The library didn't have anything to sell.
They just had all of this collective memory.
MIT gives it a budget.
So this is-- you know, there's also a market
in intelligence.
I think, for one thing, that your definition
is contextually suggested.
So in many ways, at MIT, what intelligence
is is this sort of back formation from artificial
intelligence.
And if we were--
And a back formation there from cybernetics--
If we were in government--
--which were military guidance systems.
But if we were in government and political
science, we would think that intelligence
maybe was gathering satellite and human intelligence
data from places and trying to integrate it
to learn things about other countries and
actors.
And at MIT, it's also a techno-scientific
category, whereas that's the tool with which--
that's the discourse with which to approach
it, right?
Rather than intelligent design.
Rather than with the tools of a particular
religious cosmology.
That's why I'm trying to push the conversation
within my work, my questions I'm asking myself,
as far away from any anthropomorphization,
human associated.
But also machining into other realms, into
[? alien ?] intelligence, into microbial intelligence,
into non-organic intelligence, like intelligence
of particles.
Because I think that one of the problems is
that we associated all this.
And I think a lot of these notions were exactly
created on the basis of certain cliches that
emerged in various fields.
And we have to take it somewhere.
And for me, in one word, like the intelligence,
like if really something is the unknown.
Something that is-- I'm looking for it in
the unknown, the irrational, the other worldly.
And because all these other categories we've
kind of, I fell, almost like hit the wall.
And it's just--
To go back to--
Maybe-- I was going to see if we could have
maybe one or two more questions.
But is it.
There was one in back, yes.
I'm also [INAUDIBLE] Apart from [INAUDIBLE]
I'm sorry.
I didn't-- can you rephrase the question?
It's a question as to whether we have new
discoveries on slime mold,s which I must admit,
I do not.
I have some.
But Agnieszka may be able to fill us in.
I don't know if maybe you came up late to
the talk, but I was showing that image of
slime mold solving a maze.
Most recently, what was established about
the slime mold is that it has memory.
It's capable of collectively memorizing.
Which kind of also refers to the question
about intelligence, because, of course, remembering
and learning.
It has a capability of learning, even though
it doesn't have a nervous system.
So it's, in a way, similar to a neural network.
That it somehow learns.
I have a book to recommend, which is-- there's
a professor at Princeton who has spent his
life with these organisms, kind of along the
model of the wonderful Japanese researcher
who presented them to the emperor in 1930
as the model of a good society.
Anyway, the guy at Princeton's last name is
Bonner.
And the book is just called The Social Ameobae.
And it's beautifully illustrated, and it's
small.
It's lovely to read.
And he talks about all the things that are
known and the much larger things that aren't
known about how this creature organizes.
And it's in the family of fungi, right?
We don't know much about fungi.
They are everywhere.
And they are-- the plants are down here in
the evolutionary line.
Animals are here in the evolutionary line.
And fungi are-- they're kind of right up there.
They act collaboratively.
They provide communication channels for other
symbiotic creatures that they're involved
with-- trees.
I mean, so stay tuned, because the fungi are
giving us a lot of the chemical signalling
that is just beginning to be seen as intelligent.
I'm with you on [INAUDIBLE].
I want to ask, though, about the idea that
repetition of previous states and shapes,
in that we call this memory.
I mean, we also have a memory foam pillow
that does this.
And we wouldn't attribute it with the intelligence.
In fact, the fact that our computers have
memory is not the way that Babbage, of course,
talked of them.
He talked of not the processor and memory,
but the mill and the store.
So he had the industrial metaphor for computing.
And our computer would be spoken of much more
like in these factory terms, except for the
fact that it was later reframed as a giant
brain.
Right, but we have gigabytes on storage.
So the store-- the store does get there.
I mean, these aren't the only metaphors.
But I'm saying that we often project into
these concepts metaphorically.
And so-- not that slime molds aren't interesting.
I'm not trying to assert that in this crowd,
definitely.
But we should also be thinking about what
we are figuratively discussing and what we're
projecting onto them by having these different
concepts.
I mean, the social-- the name social, what
does that-- I mean, does that make any sense?
No.
Who knows?
Is there-- yes.
Yeah, it seems like some of the ways we have
right now of acknowledging and respecting
the sort of collective intelligence, or this
act of producing something collectively is
like profit sharing and credit sharing.
I think along those lines, I feel like thinking
about the cases of acting in a collective
with termites, or acting in a collective with
artificial intelligence kind of shows the
limits of approaching it that way.
So what might it look like to really-- what's
the equivalent of profit sharing with artificial
intelligence or with termites?
I'm not sure I understood the question.
What is the equivalent of profit sharing with
termites?
What's in it for the termites?
Yeah, what's it in for the termites, yeah.
Yes.
Well actually, I have to say, honestly, I
consciously used the termites as a model of
self-exploitation, because the termites, they
don't-- this is an interesting phenomenon
that they are almost blind.
They don't see what they're building out of,
for example.
They don't see that these are these crazy
colors, instead of like the gray or orange
or black mud.
And it was just like a really, for me, interesting
vehicle to talk about self-exploitations.
It's like, how our data is exploited, or like
how--
I have to point out, they weren't even invited
to the opening.
[LAUGHTER]
But to kind of develop further on your question,
obviously-- a question that I'm being asked
very often is OK, so you're talking about
this collective intelligence, and a collective
authorship, but at the end of the day, you're
just like a single author.
And one of the things that interests me, I
think that these questions of singular authorship,
we're really witnessing some sort of erosion
of the singular author.
But it's not that we're already-- I don't
really know.
This is one of my areas of inquiry.
Where is it going to go?
I just know that individual authorship is
kind of eroding.
And we can see it already in science.
We can see it in knowledge production.
In individual arts, as Caroline pointed out,
they will be the last to go, absolutely.
I couldn't agree more.
But for example, when you look at science,
how Nobel Prize used to be just given to a
single person.
More recently, there's a kind of uptick there.
Because more recently, not only is given to
groups of people.
Sometimes a team of two, three, four scientists.
But also, more interestingly, it's given simultaneously
to two or three people who discovered the
same thing in different parts of the world.
And I think that this is an interesting development
that may lead to something else, and also
in the field of culture.
But we may not be witnessing this.
I just think that something is changing.
And I'm happy to be witnessing this.
But where it's going to go, I don't know.
And I want to just add that if you want to
see the models of profit on the animal kingdoms
and the fungal kingdoms, I mean, brewer's
yeast was the first animal to be-- I mean,
the first fungi to be sequenced.
It is the origin of the word biotechnology,
the brewer's yeast.
So we've been exploiting these branches for
a long, long time.
And what's interesting is that humans reflect
on these practices.
So humans are saying, well, it was fine to
have a couple of pigs, but 7,000 in a windowless
container, is that fine?
So in my own work, I'm interested in these
modes of visibilization, and the fact that
we create architectures with no windows because
some part of our culture is nervous that the
question, what's in it for the pigs, is going
to come up.
When we're just-- we've engineered them to
have six months lifespans where they triple
in size on particular kinds of feed.
I mean, we're producing them as machines to
feed us.
And so the question of ethics of these relationships,
it's being addressed, but in very personalized
ways that fit with the neoliberalism.
Did you eat a hamburger today?
Rather than what is our collective responsibility
to this planet and to the life forms?
Should we always maximize human life?
I mean, is that part of the co-organization?
So these questions of the collective are still
pressing and make me want to cry, because
we need to have these conversations all the
time.
We need to talk.
So I really value your question.
Well, I do as well.
Caroline, I think that one of the things about
it is that it also brings the question down
to the specifics of, how do we collaborate?
Not how do we solve every global problem related
to industrial agriculture and ecological disaster
and so on.
But how is it that we, in our own practices,
could be fairer to crowdsourced labor that
we employ.
But how do we think about this in relationship
to other sort of machine, animal, unusual
collaborations?
But how do we situate that in what we might
do as people working in art science, or as
others thinking about those types of collaborations?
Yes.
So we kind of gave this horrible perversion
of the [INAUDIBLE] challenging the way you
purchase things from the Amazon or the eBay.
So I know that Jeff Bezos son goes here, so
if I were to bump into him, what would you
recommend I pass along as a renaming Mechanical
Turk?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
Distributed automaton.
Do you have an idea?
I'm pretty excited in terms of the power of
reframing these different metaphors for work
and these different metaphors for intelligence.
And how that lets you reframe the person who
asks the questions.
I'm super excited about fungal networks and
mushrooms.
I would probably go ask-- if you come across
Paul Stamets, but he lectures on mushrooms
while wearing a mushroom as a hat.
And is an inspired creator.
I would probably knock on his door and ask
what he means by intelligence.
A sort of intelligence which makes up the
world's largest and the world's oldest organism,
and which forms a sort of intelligence that
creates a forest over hundreds of years I
think offers a lot of challenges to that sort
of single author versus collective force question.
It offers a lot of challenges to the short
term profit versus long term world question.
So I'd add mushrooms.
There's some good mushroom names, puffballs.
But you're asking about different kinds of
framings and language, right?
So people do use the word clicklabor.
But what are some other terms?
Click bait.
I mean, maybe there would be a way to name
it that-- I don't know how exploited that
it is.
So somebody is working for IBM and they're
bored, so they go over here and make a dollar.
I mean, is it terribly exploitative?
I mean, it's far worse how Apple is polishing
its cases in China, the toxic chemicals.
So maybe there's a name for it, where maybe
we would call it distracted cognitive capital.
Distracted cognitive capitalism
[LAUGHTER]
That sounds wonderful.
Time you ripped off from your boss, when it
looked like you were working, or something
like that.
I mean, maybe there's be a way to name it--
You should ask, what Joseph Weizenbaum would
say about this is what I think.
The idea that framing human activity in computation
terms, and putting this type of-- essentially,
stuffing people into the automaton of the
Mechanical Turk.
It's not so much that-- it's not the reference
to Turkey that's the problem there.
It's actually a deeper problem of how the
project is formulated, that right now, we're
using people to do some tasks that happen
to be part of what computers can do.
As soon as we get that figured out, we won't
have to deal with that.
And so--
I do want to point out that the giant conversation
could be what about the three day workweek?
What about everybody gets the same wage?
I mean, there's so many conversations that
we could be having in this universe, instead
of we're replacing all the truck drivers.
They're going to vote for Republicans.
I mean, we have such an impoverished imaginary
around how to have this conversation, it's
as though we, in our-- I love the-- I'm coming
back to Adam's metaphor again of culture as
this depositive memory.
I mean, we've just forgotten the other part
of the collective conversation, which is the
social collective that tries to make things
better for everybody in general.
Not for a few people in particular.
I mean, we've just kind of forgotten that
whole conversation.
Well, for me, for example, the ways in which
like the Amazon Mechanical Turk, and all these,
what I call just like this first factory,
I mean, in a way, it's like I think Marx's
worst dream.
Because it's 100% alienation, because everybody's
working in front of their computer screen.
And the possibilities of unionization exists,
but are not as easy as people interacting
physically.
And of course, social media plays some role
in it.
But I think one of the aspects of this topic
that interest me is flows of social energies,
and how this changes with acceleration through
circulation or content and means and everything,
social media, and how much we still need physical
bodies and physical interactions between people.
And obviously, questions about this new working
class that is emerging in front of our eyes
right now raises questions of, are we going
to have an equivalent of a revolution against
this, and against the exploitations in this
new emerging working class?
And whether the platforms such as social media
will allow for an accelerated process for
people to unionize or do something else in
order to make the world better, make the working
conditions better, and equitable, and so on
or not.
And another point that I wanted to also answer
to, what Caroline has been saying about, the
questions of how can the social make things
better is through collective intelligence.
The reason why I'm, in my working, employing
this idea of collective Tamagotchi that I
was thinking a lot about is that I realized
that there were about, I think, 76 million
Tamagotchis-- so these toys in the shape--
the egg shaped toys-- sold worldwide.
76 million.
But what if, actually, one could imagine that
all these people that built these Tamagotchis
would just take care of just one Tamagotchi?
And we have this Tamagotchi.
It's the plant earth, basically.
It's also an egg shaped that we can take care
all.
And obviously, people are self-organizing
in various ways to take care of this collective
Tamagotchi.
And this is a process of collective intelligence--
self-organization.
It's an emergent process.
Not everything is just top down organized
by politicians and governments.
But there are things.
And maybe, to answer your earlier question
about is there anything positive anyway, as
we're coming probably towards an end [INAUDIBLE]
this conversation, there maybe is something
positive.
It's that so many people around the world
are involving and self-organizing into this
debate about climate change, which I think
is positive.
Mm-hmm.
Well, and that's obviously one of the many
topics that Caroline mentioned that we have
to discuss, as well as things more directly
rising from the conversation we've had.
So I think we should move to informal conversation
at this point.
I think we should conclude.
Thanks to those who came, and thanks to the
the panelists.
Thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]